[Música]
hoy les voy a contar una historia de una
persona que me ha impactado mucho en mi
vida las contracciones cada vez eran más
fuertes y frecuentes ella sabía que muy
pronto iba a tener en manos a su pequeña
bebé llegando al hospital tenía la misma
impresión y admiración que las mujeres
que están a punto de convertirse en
madrid- no importaba si va a ser su
primera vez o no a la nueva madre no
linda no le interesa seguir las
indicaciones exactamente como el médico
le había indicado durante el parto a
veces existen complicaciones por el peso
y el gran tamaño de la bebé se quedó
atascada en el canal de parto sin poder
nacer pasaron minutos 8 angustiosos
minutos sin que el médico recibirá
signos vitales de la pequeña
bajaron y de fuerzas fue como sacaron a
la bebé pero todavía los esfuerzos no se
habían acabado la bebé no podía respirar
los médicos intentaban de resucitar a la
bebé los impacientes padres se estaban y
se abrazaban todos temían lo peor un
grito agudo significaba que la bebé se
había aferrado a la vida su corazoncito
había empezado a latir otra vez el
nacimiento forjado había ocasionado una
lesión cerebral severa ocasionada por el
tiempo que la bebé estuvo sin oxígeno y
para sacar de este mundo un forcejeo
dejó como secuela un daño muy importante
en el brazo izquierdo brazo omóplato los
médicos no muy optimistas le dijeron a
los apesebrados padres que la bebé iba a
sobrevivir prívate una vida muy corta y
difícil y que el mayor tiempo de su vida
ahí va a tener postrada en la cama como
un vegetal
ella había nacido muerto o necesitado y
tenido uno de los peores diagnósticos
que un ser humano pudiera tener pasaron
los meses y la bebé todavía no responde
a ningún estímulo
pero aún así le daban besos abrazos y le
decía cuánto la querían
poco a poco la bebé fue respondiendo a
esos estímulos lentamente pero él
respondió a sus papás ya su familia que
nunca pero nunca perdieron la esperanza
para rendirse
ella había sobrevivido tenido enormes
dificultades y una infancia difícil pero
aún así aprendió a caminar y hablar
ella es mi tía hija de mis abuelos y
hermana menor de mi mamá
mi abuelo me cuenta que contenía tres
años dijo su primer palabra me lo cuenta
con una sonrisa en el rostro ya que
frecuentemente la sacaba a caminar desde
su casa hasta el supermercado y en una
ocasión se acercó y le dijo nada
refiriéndose de manera incompleta al
nombre del supermercado le estaba
pidiendo salir a su paseo frecuente
mi mamá le cantaba canciones a lupita su
pequeña hermanita y una de sus canciones
favoritas era la de bar min
te quiero yo y tú a mí
es una familia feliz y lupita siempre se
liquida y siempre se le quedaba mirando
tiene una educación con mamá empezó a
cantar te quiero yo
lupita de manera sorpresiva le responde
y tú a mí mi mamá se queda sorprendida
porque fue la oración más larga que ella
había dicho en otra ocasión con otra de
sus hermanas mi tía cintia fueron a los
juegos mecánicos de la feria local en
eso lupita se queda con demencia no
viendo una de las atracciones en eso mi
tía decide llevarla y terminando la
atracción
lupita le responde me gustó
cada paso cada cada palabra cada sonrisa
de lupita se ha celebrado como un regalo
un pequeño milagro para toda la familia
y para sus papás
le llamamos ha dejado de sorprender
aunque tenga una deformación de su brazo
se van a quedar sorprendidos ella
aprendió a nadar hasta incluso a niveles
competitivos
algunas personas no entienden a lupita
la causa de su lesión cerebral y ya
tiene poca dificultad para medir y
modular su comportamiento social ella es
muy cariñosa y le gusta demostrar su
efecto de un agarrón de cabezas pero
como les cuento unas personas les
responde que te traes que te pasa o
retírate
pero siempre cuando la conoces es como
si fuera tu mejor amiga
en una ocasión mi abuela me cuenta
cuando estaba en la natación
lupita agarró de la cabeza a un niño
y en eso el papá del niño se fija por
los miradores del acuática
muy enojado y le van a elevar gritando a
lupita y lupita solo se le queda mirando
en eso mi abuelo se da cuenta y baja a
discutir con ese señor
en eso esa discusión llegó hasta la
oficina de aquella institución en eso el
señor dice a mí no me gusta que nadie
ande tocando a la cabeza de mi hijo esta
niña tiene que estar en una institución
que no sean para niños normales en eso
mi abuelo le cuenta los problemas que el
hospital y ha tenido pero aún así el
señor no le hace caso
pero por suerte la institución apoya
lupita
lloret a los 21 años ella sigue nadando
ella ha ganado 40 medallas y lo que yo
me recuerdo es el año pasado en donde
quedó en un octavo lugar en mundial
a veces yo me quedo pensando quisiera
del niño al que lupita le agarró la
cabeza yo pienso que no le dio miedo el
agarrón que lupita le dio sino el
sobrecogido que le dio su papá a veces
yo me quedo muy triste con el ejemplo
que le dan sus papás a los hijos porque
después cuando el hijo crece le dais el
mismo ejemplo a sus hijos y así hasta
que puede cambiar
uno de esos hijos ya que eso está mal
el mundo sería un mejor lugar si
nuestros corazones tuviéramos un espacio
para la compasión aunque ya un pequeño
espacio estuviéramos uno más grande pues
estuviera mucho mejor
mis abuelos ya están acostumbrados a las
miradas furtivas a las miradas
desesperación ya la lupita aparece
tampoco importarle
lupita no sólo es una buena oradora
también es el alma de la reunión
familiar es donde le gusta amenizar
cantando y bailando y dar a conocer a
todos su alegría siempre cuando es
cantando
gusta el coro y siempre cuando es
bailando busca con chavela no se le
ponga enfrente
y ella en estos días está estableciendo
una plática más larga y eso es muy bueno
haciendo mucho fue a un campamento de
selectivos para natación sin el
acompañamiento de los papás y esta tiene
dos cosas buenas que ya fue ingresada de
nuevo al mundial y que fue sin el
acompañamiento de sus papás y eso es muy
bien es muy bueno porque luego en un
futuro puede ir sola a donde ella quiera
ir
5 de cada 100 personas
con discapacitados y pueden ser niños
adolescentes o adultos que a veces son
rechazados por sus comunidades hasta
incluso por sus familias
la intolerancia la falta de compasión la
ignorancia el miedo esta es la verdadera
discapacidad taras de una sociedad
egoísta y cruel
yo siempre cuando tengo una tarea
difícil un examen que se me hace mucho
muy complicado o una dificultad con una
persona solo pienso en las dificultades
que lupita ha tenido y sigue teniendo y
así solo pienso que mis problemas no son
tan grandes como a veces yo pienso que
son y así es como yo los cumplo y así es
como yo los voy cumpliendo y cumpliendo
lupita para nuestra familia ha sido como
una campeona una guerrera un atenas y
nuestra gran lupita gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]